brennon you want to be a writer you
can't write you have to actually take an
action that moves you forward getting
very clear on the mission
I think doubt is one of the greatest
enemies of our lives so if you go to any
meeting sit down and say guys I have 45
minutes today for this meeting the time
to have the map is before you enter the
woods get back in the game we have a
community of people who are giving you
advanced feedback before you release it
we just start trying to live a life
that's not even our own I had nobody
ever really told me I had any potential
before I have to change myself he's an
American author on motivation high
performance and online marketing he's
the founder of the experts academy and
high performance Academy he's the number
one New York Times bestselling author of
The Millionaire messenger
he's Brendon Burchard and here are his
top ten rules for success no matter
where you are in accomplishing your
dreams or moving towards the things that
you really want in life never let your
your small beginnings make you small
minded it's easy to say well that's
impossible and I know lots of people are
telling you that that's impossible you
know many people told me what I'm doing
today is impossible Brendon you want to
be a writer you can't write better you
you ought to be a trainer you wanna be a
speaker you want to youtube videos
you're not good on video you're not this
you're not gonna this it's impossible oh
you don't understand how hard it is to
make it Brendon it's so hard these days
the stuff that people tell me and I know
told you is so nonsensical and based on
so many of their own fears that have
been unexplored that it's sad and it can
really cause great people to stop trying
to do great things so I want to
encourage you no matter where you are
believe in yourself keep ad keep working
keep going I mean success and
fulfillment are going to come from your
unflagging ability to believe in what
other people call impossible it's going
to come from your unflagging ability to
get up each day and work towards things
that maybe you don't know where they're
going maybe they're not getting you what
you want writing it way maybe it's not
easy maybe it is a struggle but it is
through that struggle and that effort
and that dream and the desire that you
get there
you have to actually show up every day
and inch yourself forward toward these
streams and not only show up every day
and once in a while into yourself I mean
every day you have to actually take an
action that moves you forward not just
research not just thinking look the
power of an intention is great but
without any initiative it's dead right a
dream is great but without any movement
it's dead you have to be moving towards
every day you can send an email every
day you can make a call every day you
can write something every day you can
create something every day you can
contribute something every day but it
has to be daily otherwise it will never
become actualized and the highest
performers in the world didn't get there
because they were lucky they worked at
it longer than everyone else they had a
better work ethic and it's not that they
necessarily always worked harder they
work smarter because they were doing the
research they were taking the time to
visualize how they would be distinct
different how they would survive the
tough times they really kept at it keep
every single day momentum going and if
you don't do that there's no chance you
must define your mission you need to
have a mission for what you're doing
today you need to have an intention for
what your next task is going to be what
happens most people just kind of show up
and they go okay well I guess I'll do
some stuff but they have no intention
whatsoever so they end up doing too many
things that mean nothing towards their
mission you should figure out what is it
you desire in life and figure out the
steps to get there and start working a
plan to get there and minimizing
everything else getting very clear on
the mission very clear on the mission
and working the plan everything else
guess what it gets a no until you reach
that mission or until you're
significantly on your way that you have
free resources to be able to focus
elsewhere and that's what people do they
take on too many projects because
they're not clear about their mission
because I'm guessing if you're watching
this you know you're somebody who wants
to add value and make a difference in
the world so any time someone to ask you
to do something yeah let me help you but
that might not have anything to do with
the quality
life or the objective or the thing that
you're trying to achieve or the service
you're really intending to offer right
and I know how hard it is because I'm so
pulled myself towards causes and towards
volunteerism towards helping so many
people but guess what if I help
everybody in lots of different areas I
might not make my ultimate mission of
serving the people I want to serve the
most of making my dreams come true so I
could support more people of running my
business so I can support more people
meaning it's easy to take your eye off
the ball if you don't know what the ball
is and people often have never defined
their mission and if you don't have one
right now for this day if you didn't
have them drive a mission a written down
statement about what you were going to
accomplish today a checklist a goal
sheet a time management tool that you
filled out today and you're just showing
up today and going well I guess I'll see
what my inbox tells me to do today and
you just respond to everybody else's
desires and everyone else's emails and
usually always in reaction always
responding to everybody no proactivity
towards a mission that you defined
yourself you'll be lost you'll find that
because you never focused on that one
thing or moving towards those several
things that were your priority that
you're just lost because and here's
another thing focus goes out the window
when we don't have progress right if
we're not progressing toward something
our focus goes out the window we just we
don't pay attention to anything we don't
feel good about ourselves you want to
get more focus in your life get more
progress as you progress the more you
start to get excited you start to pay
attention to things that are working
that are moving you forward and you
start to find more focus in your life
first anything we all have is doubt you
know we doubt whether or not we're
capable we doubt whether or not we're
worthy we doubt whether or not we'll
succeed we doubt whether or not we even
deserve it and it's so unfortunate
because I think doubt is one of the
greatest enemies of our lives and it's
so easy to overcome but most people
won't practice the discipline of
overcoming it which is weird right there
say oh I'm so doubtful and they stop and
it's like if you have any negative
recurring emotion in your
life doesn't maturity require you to
face it and say hey how do I fix this
you know if you're always doubtful you
can't just wander around say oh I'm so
doubtful like some kind of victim that
that's not fair to the humanity you've
been given that that real power of free
will that says hey you can direct your
consciousness that's why you have this
big prefrontal cortex other animals
can't we can so handle it if you've been
plagued without your whole life then
face it stop running from it I know that
sounds hard to sane people I was I have
the same story
I was so doubtful that people won't care
about what I say
I was so doubtful that people would want
to read my books or listen to me at all
I was so doubtful I could chase my own
dreams and I realized for what reason am
i doubtful because of past failures in
the space no I'm trying something new
because people told me I might not be
able to do it so what makes them an
expert on my capabilities and my
potentialities I thought well why am I
so doubtful
we're doubtful because the germ of fear
spread in our body because somebody
planted it there one time or we
cultivate it with our own thoughts and
at some point maturity and consciousness
says if doubt has been plaguing you
let's have a look at it and let's
realize well how do you banish it well
every single thing that we know from
spirituality from philosophy from the
great writers in the great text of human
culture has all revealed one thing where
there is doubt grant me faith that we
have to have faith and faith does not
mean the absent of doubt matter of fact
the very definition of faith realize
that doubt is still there right you
can't have faith unless there's some
part of you says well I'm going to go
anyway despite the doubt so I'm not
saying we have to get rid of doubt
forever and handle it I'm saying doubt
should never prevent you from advancing
when you feel like advancing that in
your own mind you must say ok I must
trust in my abilities I must trust that
I will figure it out I must trust it I
can build it I must trust that I can get
some help
and
progress even though the doubt might be
there look the hero is a hero because
the hero does it anyway right even
though the hero's terrified and risking
it all goes anyway and we're all heroes
in some way we can all be courageous but
I also think you know what society
overblow is courage
society says you know courage has to be
some big magnificent act but it's not I
mean courage in this world anymore is
just haven't of the belief in yourself
and having the ability to genuinely
express who you are if you're doubting
yourself the only way through is give
yourself more faith and take more action
and with more faith and more action
comes more competence with more
competence comes more confidence in
psychology they call it the confidence
confidence loop right the more you learn
and try the more you master and develop
so go out there even with that yes let
the doubt be there but do it anyway to
be more explicit in communicating your
boundaries be more explicit and
communicating your time so if you're
going to want a meeting sit down and say
guys I have 45 minutes today for this
meeting can't go a second over and like
oh okay and stop going over on your
times if you said you were gonna work
out for an hour work out for an hour
stop go a lot of the what I call bleed
time ends up taking away from our
balance bleed time is those things where
you're you go over on things that you
didn't need to go over on you know that
that one cocktail with your friend and
it'll be on sixteen you know and you
lost the entire night now or that one
you know lunch meeting you're gonna have
turned into four hours and now you've
lost the day of work or that one show
you're gonna watch before getting back
to work turn into a whole season and
you're like oh no the day the night is
gone
that's called bleed time it's where so
much time just dissipates because you
didn't stick to your mark so set your
boundary communicate it clear with
people and don't go over on things
anymore a lot of people if they just
started with the intention set we're
only gonna do this for this much time
and then we got to go if they stuck to
that they would get better balance if
you're really going to get ahead
you have to study your craft you have to
deeply study you know I I decided what
was it now 18 years ago that I wanted to
help inspire and motivate people and I
wanted to coach people one on one on
motivation on high performance
I wanted to write books on the topics so
18 years ago I started reading a book a
week on psychology leadership
communication marketing and there.good
on my hand about human behavior and high
performance I was studying everything I
could in psychology every single week
now it's like people like wait you've
read a book a week for 17 years I don't
brag about I'm not like oh yeah look at
me that was for my passion I knew if I
really wanted to succeed at something I
had to study it and I had to study it
deeply and I couldn't you know spend all
this time doing a lot of things so I had
to study my craft the great artists of
our past history that's what they did
they did one thing they had a true level
of depth of study in that area now maybe
they dabbled in some other areas too but
they became famous because they study in
one area and so what's your area what's
the thing you need to study on develop a
deep level of competence into how to do
it and how that world works because you
know we have a saying in Montana that
the time to have the map is before you
enter the woods but a lot of people have
a dream and they run out into the woods
and they just start trying stuff and
they take this path and this path and
this path and this path and because they
didn't study best practices they've
sunday one you know they wake up and
they're lost they're confused about who
they are and where they're at and
they're in this dark forest of the
unknown with no plan to get out they had
no idea they just jumped into something
they didn't study before taking that
leap and I would say you know what study
pay attention learn from the best model
and most intelligent smart successful
people you can in any given area that
you want to succeed in in your life
before you get into it
then develop competency by doing it over
and over and over and over again don't
do it once in a while here and there
over and over and over that's how you
get competence you need to get in a
community where you can get feedback you
need either a coach who can give you
some direct one-to-one feedback or
community of friends who just go out
with me
to lunch to them once a month you share
everything you're doing they give you
some feedback or you shoot a video you
send that video out to everybody get
some feedback on it you create a pour it
by the PowerPoint practice it with five
people before the big meeting like get
back in the game we have a community of
people who are giving you advanced
feedback before you release it feedback
before you do it
so that you get smarter at all this
because you know nothing makes a dream
come more into life than when you start
getting feedback from other people about
your movement toward the dreams you know
before I shoot a big sales video for one
of my online courses I'll send it out to
1520 people and get feedback and then
off and go reshoot it again you know or
I'll put it out into my community and
I'll see the clicks the conversions and
say it's not let's do it again
and it's that willingness to get the
feedback that will keep your dream alive
because look if it's just in your mind
and you just doing it by yourself but
you never actually get a positive
community giving you constructive
feedback towards it it will never be
that but that it will never be in the
social realm and when it is in the
social realm it feels more real you know
when people actually comment I mean it's
one thing to be in an artist and in your
studio painting for yourself all day
that's great but once you get some
feedback on it and constructive feedback
you become you get that self-awareness
and that social awareness to contribute
and create at another level what is it
you're really after and is it after what
you are you after enough for yourself
are you are you limiting yourself based
on your current competencies a lot of
people do that they narrow their vision
or their ambition for tomorrow based on
what they can do today or who they are
today without realizing they can develop
their mastery their skills their
competency their knowledge their
experience without realizing they can
become a better person they can live
into their highest self they can live
into the type of person who could
accomplish those goals
who could have those things so never
limit your ambitions based on your
current competencies never limit
yourself today based on your current
inadequacies because those can be
irrelevant
tomorrow the main thing is to have a min
life to have your own name to have your
own ambitions not the ambition somebody
told you you should have or someone told
you you're supposed to be after because
that's how we all get on sort of you
know sometimes a corporate treadmill or
we get on those things where we just
start trying to live a life that's not
even our own because we're just going
with everybody but ambition liberates
that your individual ambition who you
want to become what you want to do what
you want to contribute and the highest
forms of all ambition usually come down
to your creative expression your
contribution and your connection with
others that creative expression what is
it you want to create in this world and
I mean get your hands dirty doing you
know not just create some PowerPoint
once in a while for some corporate thing
but something real and meaningful that
you consider art for yourself whatever
that is even if it is a PowerPoint
presentation right but to do something
that you find artistic and meaningful
that's our human drive for creative
expression then what about contribution
what's your ambition to give and to
serve greatly for others what do you
really want to give back or give to
others what is it and what about
connection you know the ultimate
ambition and aim to have I think for a
lot of people is their relationships to
operate and have a love that knows no
bounds I mean a love that is
extraordinary that it is amazing you
can't improve your relationship with
your family or your spouse or those that
you serve unless you have in some sense
about you that desire to love or give or
connect more so today
get clear what is it you want and is it
big enough for yourself not limiting
yourself based off your inadequacies
your competencies but based on what you
truly desire last challenge take
whatever that is that you come up with
and 10x it take it by 10 times what
would be ten times that admission not
just because it's silly I know I know
it's kind of silly but to take that
ambition that you initially have which
is usually a
what we usually want is an impulse based
on who we are today I just challenge
people don't think bigger for yourself
because you are a mints you are
magnificent you are powerful beyond your
current understandings so break through
that another level challenge your brain
to think even bigger for yourself even
it's just Evans activity to break the
bounds of your current beliefs and
behaviors you deserve something
extraordinary in your life but at first
you have to want it what makes a great
person these days what really makes
someone extraordinary what makes
somebody stand out what's going to make
you feel like you're contributing your
best like you're making your difference
and that you're always aspiring to be
better human but you're also achieving
along the way I would argue that that
thing that makes us great is generosity
you know the ability to be generous to
others with your time your attention
your mentorship your care your love your
patience your forgiveness your
understanding your spirit your energy
when you are generous with who you are
people vibrate with that they feel it
they sense it and they're surprised by
you know in a world today we're known
we'll even take time to say hello or to
call somebody or to show knit a measure
of appreciation when you do that you
stand out but you also light up in your
soul you know it changes everything when
you're willing to be different when
you're willing to be generous with
people because really you know it's a
very biblical thing ask and you shall
receive I also think that in terms of
career and in terms of chasing your
dreams give and you shall receive you
know give as much of your heart and your
spirit in your life in your voice to
this world this time this day this
person in front of you because we only
get one shot at this life and today it
never happens you don't see it you know
I'm blessed to be here and shooting this
video at my writers villa where I come
to write and now shoot these episodes
and and I can share with you you know
all this when I got here and then what I
think about this space it
it came from a place position of
generosity and came from a position of
generosity in my life so long ago when I
had a high school mentor mrs. Ballew who
believed in me
she saw me take some pictures and she
said you know those pictures are pretty
good even though honestly looking back
they were kind of crap but she cheered
me on anyway because I was putting
effort and she could see how it's kind
of passionate about it and she said you
know you could probably write and and
you could probably shoot these uh you
shoot these uh the photographs and I had
nobody ever ever really told me I had
any potential before and here's this
person for no reason saying you could
probably do this and I started doing it
and she'd cheer me on and cheer me on
and her generosity of her time or effort
or mentorship she wasn't there was no
reason she did it she just believed in
me but you know what she believed in
everybody around her she was always
cheering people on always rewarding
effort always telling people to pursue
their passions and believe in themselves
and I'm here today I get to do this work
with you and millions of people see
these videos and hear me online or watch
my posts online or read my emails every
single week because this woman who was a
teacher at a simple high school in a
simple town with a simple beautiful
generous spirit said I believe in your
kid I remember when I was going to start
my business and I really wanted to be
good at it you know I was trying to
become an author and a speaker and do
these types of videos and do some online
training for people on the topics of
motivation and marketing and you know
some all these people are saying well
Brendan you know you may or may not be
successful that you're you know blah and
I thought weird thing it's not like
there's a trait of successful people you
look across history and successful
people it's not they're not from a given
background they don't come from a
specific economic stature they're not in
a position where you know they're their
one demographic or another Democrats all
over I mean we've got thousands of
collective years of history people
succeed some people do some people don't
and I think it more comes down to how do
we manage our mind and how do we manage
our days and I think that there's a
difference between successful people and
unsuccessful people in the way they
particularly think about approaching
something new
you know I think unsuccessful people
when they have a big dream and they
start thinking about what's going to be
required to accomplish that dream they
get very limiting in their beliefs about
themselves and what's possible and
specifically they say three types of
things you know the first thing they
often say is well you know I don't know
how to do that
so they stop they say you know I I don't
have those things so they stop or they
say I don't know you know I'm not like
those people I'm not like that
and so they stop but successful people
have a different way they have the same
thing everybody dreams you dream I dream
successful people dream people just
starting out everybody dreams everyone
has a vision everyone if they can just
take five minutes today and think about
their lives we could all come up with
ways to improve our lives and reach
another level of success joy happiness
achievement contribution fulfillment
soul you know we can all elevate but the
challenge is that them successful people
they keep stopping when they think of
what they currently know have or are but
successful people say well I want to do
that but I don't know how to do that but
instead of stopping they say well then
my job is to go learn that they take
their current limitation and they put it
on their agenda as a job to do as a
thing to figure out a thing to make
happen
instead of saying well I don't have that
they say well then my job is to go build
that or I'm not like that then they say
well then my job is to go become more of
that become that person who could
accomplish those things
you know when I was starting to do
online marketing for the first time and
and I don't know if you know how much of
my story you know but when I started
doing online marketing I was literally
bankrupt and I went from a place of
bankruptcy to the point where I really
committed to becoming successful at it
and in 18 months I made four point eight
million dollars four point six collected
I mean
a huge leap right in in indifference
from bankrupt to multi-millionaire in a
span of 18 months but what made that
breakthrough wasn't that I had new
opportunities it wasn't that I had new
technologies it was like wow there's the
Internet now those things were already
there it went I went from this level of
thinking to this level of thinking I
used to say well I I don't know how to
build a webpage so I said agenda figure
out how to build a webpage and I spent
hours and hours and hours at nights on
weekends for my job figuring out how to
do that and I said well I don't have one
of those lists you know I don't have any
subscribers nobody knows who I am
so I said job go build a list
go get subscribers go add value and
content out the marketplace and they'll
come I mean just keep putting stuff out
there and I also didn't say oh my gosh
well I have that dream I can't have that
because I'm not like that because I
wasn't a public speaker I didn't know
how to do video I wasn't like well I'm
not one of those video people well I'm
not a public speaker so I said you know
what I have to go learn that art I have
to go become a better speaker a better
communicator I have to go become more
confident I have to go become a person
capable of doing these things I have to
change myself to get there I can't wait
for circumstances to change so I can
have my dream then our dreams would
never happen we have to get to the point
of maturity in our lives where we say
okay two things going to change my life
something new is going to come into my
life and make me lucky and blessed and
maybe I can't count on that forever and
maybe now instead I have to consciously
design my life and say okay now if I
want to change if I want my dream
something new has to come from me I'm
going to become a better person I'm
going to become a person who is more
optimistic who is more confident who is
more driven not because I am that now
but because we can grow that you can
become the type of person who needs to
who you need to be to achieve your ideal
life you can start today living from
your highest ideals your highest sense
of self your strongest sense of self you
don't need permission you don't need a
guy like me to look at the video camera
and say you have now permission but if
been waiting for it you have from
it's like at some point in your life you
just say okay I have permission to
become my best self and by becoming your
best self you start to achieve your best
things you start to contribute better
things you start to become a better
human being you can do that now today so
next time you're thinking about a big
dream don't think about the things that
well I don't know how to do that and
stop think I don't know how so set it up
on your calendar to go learn those
things I don't have that then set it up
step by step to go build that I'm not
like that then set it up step by step to
go develop those skill sets and those
competencies so you can become that and
ultimately you can achieve that dream
it's there it's waiting for you don't
stop thank you so much for watching I
made this video because Priscilla asked
me to so there's a thing with
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of Brendon bouchard's top 10
rules meant the most to you had the
biggest impact leave it in the comments
and I'll join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon
the first thing you have to do in order
to improve your mind is take total
control of your attention and notice
where are your thoughts right now at a
very continual basis you have to think
where are my thoughts right now are they
supporting me or are they automatically
coming up- and self-protective in ways
that are not advancing my life just to
be aware to be conscious of what's going
on in your body in your sense of feeling
and emotion and the sense of the
thoughts you're actually having just
start paying attention you know for a
lot of people because they've never done
this before and it's hard to remind them
to do it it's like simple here's what I
want you to do just start paying
attention to your thoughts anytime
you're in line any time you're in line
from now on if you're in line at
Starbucks just say I'm in line at
Starbucks spread and said think about my
thoughts what are my thoughts saying
right now just checking it you're in
line in traffic waiting for the next car
just sitting like what are my thoughts
right now and just notice what you've
been thinking about the more did we
notice what we've been thinking about
the more we can interrupt what we've
been thinking about see if we just allow
that feeling to keep coming up and you
don't pay attention to it our life can
be very frazzled and very highly anxious
but once we say what's my mind on right
now and we redirect it that is where
personal power comes from first
awareness right and understanding and
the consciousness to what's going on but
then the ability now to be self
directive to choose what we want to
focus on so first we're attentive to it
and then redirect it if it's negative
it's not supporting you redirected how
do you redirect it first and foremost
you just say what would be the opposite
of this negative thing that you think
about the positive thing and you focus
on that and you repeat it to yourself
for many people that might include
closing their eyes just visualizing a
more positive outcome thinking about the
more positive outcome thinking about
more positive outcome thinking about the
more positive outcome focusing on with
their eyes closed and that visualization
of a more positive outcome of how things
could turn out well or how would the
situation could be better or even just
what are the next steps I should take
visualizing that and assigning a high
amount of important
thunderation to it meaning making that
thing important to us by making it how
do you make something important you give
it a sensation you feel that thing you
sense it you sense what your next step
would be you sense how and feel that the
outcome would be better how it feel
emotionally psychologically spiritually
for that thing to allow it to have a lot
of emotion to it pay attention to your
eyes close you see that thing you feel
it you sense a different step you know
what you're going to do you pay
attention to it and you keep focusing on
that so we're pure demerits keep
focusing in keep focusing focusing when
your mind automatically wants to go back
to the easy which might be negative
you're you go no no no I don't want to I
don't want
I'm not into easy right now I'm into
conditioning my mind focus focus focus
focus give attention duration and
sensation to attention duration
sensation attention to raishin sensation
visualization visual data visualization
it's repetition of that positive
alternative to a negative and pulse that
comes up that gives us personal power
you know so many people say to me well
Brendan I'm wiped out I'm tired I wish I
had your energy or whatever one I know a
lot of people don't want to have my
energy is too annoying I get it but what
if we had you tap back into your life
decision you know what if you just chose
not for any reason not for what emotions
come up in your human body because
emotions just come up right your nervous
system sometimes you don't even know why
you feel what you feel like something
can be trigger you a sound a movement
something someone says or just your
physical body of what you ate a couple
hours ago or how much you slept three
days ago can catch up to you and your
body and your motions can kind of go
choo but we have to sing the power plant
doesn't have energy it generates energy
what if your dominant frame said you
know I'm going to focus on my aliveness
and you started cultivating an aliveness
in your body and in your mind for no
other reason then I said so no other
reason that you decided to you said you
know what today I'm going to focus on
what's great about me but I'm also going
to focus on being fully alive and
engaged and president how do you do that
just what if you just felt more grateful
for the life that you had you know look
you're breathing you're you're you're
alive you we have this incredible gift
that we're all
you're right now you know it's like I'm
here you're here what if we took that
seriously and we started realizing what
a gift it is to be alive we allowed
ourselves to feel alive not for any
reason no one made us happy no one did
anything for us we just felt alive again
and we started asking ourselves on a
daily basis what level of aliveness do I
feel in my body right now do I feel at a
level zero like dead or do I feel like a
level ten I'm fully alive fully engaged
fully present and we willed ourself into
feeling more alive every day it's a
number one question I get from all of my
works like wow you have a lot of energy
on what you do how do you get it I don't
get it I don't find it I generated the
power plant doesn't have energy it
generates it if you want to feel better
about your life generate more aliveness
for no other reason than you choose to
life should be incredibly valuable to
you if you really value your days like
that day becomes valuable so because
your day is valuable you get stuff done
you know why a lot of people end up
feeling really broke is because they're
not valuing their day they're broke
because they added no value to their day
they were reaching celebrity gossip
magazines they were screwing around
online they were doing nothing that
actually moved the needle in terms of
their personal progress and their
professional progress so value this day
you want to make more money get serious
about tomorrow value that day ask how
you can add more value into the day
really work the day and as you do that
over and over and over again you ask how
can I serve how can I contribute how can
I take at the next level you do that
long enough
the breakthrough happens the magic
happens and the money
excape itself